and then Asians are three really
damn dude
with people what is your uh for people
it goes Jews oh yeah
Jews a Jews Asians blacks and whites are
tied oh blacks and white third yeah yeah
yeah oh man I wanna I wanted to be
Jewish so bad when I was a kid yeah
because of Mel Brooks all this Canadians
were Jewish Jewish Envy too I really
chew Envy I beg you envy oh man Yiddish
yeah it is calling stuff like oh look at
your took us it's look at that stuff
like that like oh oh just saying that
when something bad happens yeah I put a
little note in the wall you did yeah at
the Wailing Wall no I just did a wall I
just had a right right
yeah I hate the Jews
that would be funny to do anti-semitic
stuff by putting it in walls no I steal
all the money no I really you know when
I went to Israel I was just like I just
really I mean I haven't chosen the side
yet but you know because
what am I doing right now I'm choosing
aside I'm neutral but my point is is
that um I really you know I mean like
the culture and the people when I lived
in Tucson I was like damn dude I wish I
knew Spanish you live in Tucson yeah I
lived in Tucson five years why because I
went to U of A oh yeah and I started
comedy in Tucson at the laughs yeah it
laughs on Broadway wow there was a
one-legged lady you see there's
no she wasn't there okay she wasn't
there still but that club was like did
you hear about the one-legged lady or I
mean I saw some [__] at laughs laughing
she was like laughs is a road room it's
a road room man like you see people come
through and you're like this guy's
really fun he's on heroin like that's
the weekend where you go like you'd see
the Thursday show and you're like this
guy's so good and by Saturday you're
like man it's tough to hang out with
that it's not a bad drinking problem
yeah because anyone that was worth a
[__] wasn't working there have you ever
been to a comedy club where you look at
the headshots yeah they go who are these
people I tell you the name I always
think about yeah laughs yeah but I
always I look to see him on other clubs
Tommy blaze Tommy I know Tommy blaze
okay Tommy blaze had the wildest head
shot at laughs it was like like a
leather jacket like a Dice Clay one yeah
look like and then whenever I go to
clubs zany is in Nashville I found him
and zany is in Chicago oh that's a fun
game yeah were you like you try it's
like uh trying to collect them yeah
where all can I find but he had some old
headshots that laughs and but those
people were unfortunate because they
didn't have the internet yeah right so
that's what you had to do those are two
roads there was going on the road see if
you can like develop a following yeah or
you come to Hollywood or New York and
try to get on TV or whatever yeah but
like now you can just you know
you can just go on the road and go on
the internet and go straight to the
people right right and but like if you
look at those headshots it's super sad
it is you know my favorite one is my
favorite old school one it's at the
comic strip you can see it it's Jim
Florentine and his name is Jammin Jim
Florence
oh Jim really yeah and he's like because
that was those are the times when you
needed a hook yeah you know what I mean
yeah yeah you need to have like there's
a guy named Jackie Graham and he changed
his name to Jackie banana and wore a
yellow suit yeah because I this is the
this is the thing how old would I be
back yeah
I think I'd be like big head big head
Dan yeah
and I'd be like check out the size of my
head I'd smash things with it on a stool
like I'd be like mushy yeah yeah
I probably have like like a um you know
Cowboy Asian kind of a thing yeah
he Hawks in for sure oh
because I was looking at some of your
old all right what are you doing dude
yes I'm glad thank you for bringing this
[__] am I wrong yeah you used to wear
them you used to wear a cowboy hat
overall hair yeah
yeah because what was the what was the
energy of that okay I'll tell you the
energy so thank